it's beef brisket a super cheap cut from
the breast of the cow
it's underused in the uk but loved by
american cousins and used for incredible
delicates like pastrami and succulent
salt beef
the key to beef brisket is to cook it
low and slow to make it tender and i've
got a delicious barbecue style recipe
for dinner
[Music]
we're creating bbq style beef brisket
with crunchy coleslaw and sweet potato
wedges which will be right up her street
holly
now
you love barbecues right
so you're gonna help me barbecue this
delicious piece of brisket
brisket look at it
beautiful it's a very tough cut of meat
so it needs to be cooked slowly so it
gets really nice and tender are we
barbecuing it outside we're gonna
actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're gonna cook it in the
oven
okay
so mustard powder
okay
here we have some celery seed
next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
good
now what i want you to do
fresh pepper on there
i'll give that a little mix roll up your
little sleeves and then
i want you
to rub
all that spice
into the brisket
almost like you're massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay
in the spice
so gas on roasting tray on what we've
got to do now with all those spices is
sear them in a couple of tablespoons of
olive oil into the tray
well done okay good that's getting nice
and hot now you get your brisket
and all that spice
lay that in there nicely
okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in
you smell those spices yep all that
spice left on the plate
we're gonna use yeah
i want you to get the onions
nice and carefully slice them down not
too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
smell those spices now
good girl
thank you
damn holly
was homework that bad
no the onions oh no don't rub your eyes
don't rub your eyes
[Music]
we've got the colour
on the brisket okay yeah
take that out literally for 30 seconds
okay
onions into the tray please
nice
you see it's starting to smell slightly
barbecuey already give that a little
stir
nice
now one nice tablespoon of brown sugar
what does the brown sugar do dad so the
brown sugar we're gonna start
caramelizing the onions
right from there my bay leaves in
please good girl oh yes please
right you want to take over
good careful that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon
of tomato puree roast that off at the
bottom of the tray and really rub it in
amongst the onions good girl now look at
the colors onions
right now
time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of earring please so you
go in you put yours in there i'll put
mine here
god uh good health to you and your
brisket
good health
bring that to the ball
okay now this is where it gets really
exciting i want you to lift the brisket
up and put it on top of the onions in
she goes
good girl
and then i want you to pour the stock
all the way around please
i'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock once the stock has come to the
boil cover tightly with foil
you just pinch in the ends
flatten that down and then you just
twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoked paprika dried oregano
cayenne pepper and mix
spice mix done now simply cut your sweet
potatoes into wedges toss in olive oil
and thoroughly cover with the spice mix
onto a baking tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes turning halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh
now look at that so we can leave that to
rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what
mayonnaise that's right mayonnaise this
time
we're gonna do it a little different so
i'd like you to put the yogurt into the
bowl for me
please all of it
i'll start slicing the white cabbage
and the red cabbage
now from there a nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch
of salt and pepper
okay
now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar
in there okay as i shred this okay i'd
like you please then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix in at the same time and then you
fold that in there as i start shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now the
white
so
you've got that nice vinegary
tartness to the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh
last little bit in
one more little thing
so
put some nice
chopped
fresh chives in there and that will give
it this nice light
onion flavor
so
chives in
[Music]
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
delicious so
i would like you
to fill up the bowl i'm going to very
carefully lift out
my brisket how come is it shrunk it's
been in the oven
for nearly
three and a half hours
so it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
i'll start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first
before anybody
that is so good
that
tastes
delicious
see all that wonderful flavor in there
last job is to create an incredibly
quick and delicious sauce
gas on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in
then add in cider vinegar and you've got
a brilliant tangy barbecue sauce
that smells nice doesn't it
wow
that is brisket
and a half now the rest of it
can go in the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my dunny
is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry
the sweet potato for me i've got the
brisket wow
let's go donny well done by the way
thank you
this is a real american beauty gorgeous
low and slow cooked bbq beef brisket
with sweet potato wedges and yogurt
coleslaw
you